-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Have fun.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for tuning in.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for being here.
Today is the day everybody.
The "Friends" reunion
is now available on HBO Max.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And just like every reunion,
people were mainly excited to
see who gained the most weight.
And it's Marcel, actually.
-Is it really?
-You wouldn't
even recognize him.
The thing is so huge, though,
HBO Max is already planning
a "Friends Reunion:
The Reunion."
-Yeah.
-Really?
Each cast member was paid
$2.5 million for the special.
[ Audience ohh's ]
Meanwhile, when he heard,
Gunther was like,
"You guys got paid?
They told me
this was just for fun."
$2.5 million is a lot.
I mean, for that kind of money,
you can almost subscribe
to HBO Max and Netflix.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. The "Friends"
reunion is a big success,
and it looks like HBO Max
has even more plans
for the franchise.
Check this out.
-From the people
who brought you "Friends,"
coming soon to HBO Max,
it's "Young Gunther."
The story of a little bald boy
who dreams of someday
making cappuccinos
for hot 30-somethings.
-I don't know
if that's gonna work.
[ Applause ]
Some more entertainment news.
Amazon just reached a deal to
buy MGM studios for $8 billion.
Yeah, at this point,
the only thing Jeff Bezos
doesn't own is hair.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Amazon owns
the "James Bond" franchise.
The creators of "James Bond"
said there won't be
any obvious changes
except there's one scene
where Bond orders
two martinis
and then drunk-shops on Amazon.
-[ Laughter ]
-But check this out.
I saw that CVS is now
offering prizes for people
who get vaccinated
in their pharmacies.
Some of the prizes
are pretty great,
especially the grand prize --
the key to the locked case
where they keep all
the razors and deodorant.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Meanwhile, last night,
Ohio announced
the first two winners
of its Vax-a-Million lottery.
Yep, any vaccinated adult
was eligible to win $1 million.
That's pretty crazy,
but Ohio isn't the only state
offering incentives
to vaccinated residents.
Check out what you could win
in other states.
First up, if you get vaccinated
in Vermont,
they'll let you spoon
with either Ben or Jerry
for as long as you want.
Big spoon, little spoon.
Your choice.
Up next, if you're vaccinated
in South Dakota,
you're eligible to become
the fifth head on Mt. Rushmore.
-"Room for one more!"
-Ah. Next up, if you get
vaccinated in Florida,
you can get blackout drunk
and drive an ATV
through Walmart
without any consequences.
[ Applause ]
Actually, you can do that,
no matter what.
It's a right in Florida.
And, finally, if you get
vaccinated in Georgia,
they'll let you take a picture
with Jimmy Carter
so that you can look
like a giant.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is very interesting.
A new feature just became
available on Instagram
and Facebook that allows users
to hide likes.
No more likes?
In response,
everyone canceled their brunch
and gave away their babies.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not in it for that.
I'm not in it for that."
Listen to this.
I heard that Walmart is going --
working with Gap to launch
a new home-goods brand
called Gap Home.
That's right.
Walmart home décor.
It's the only place
you can get an Ottoman
with a lower-back tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
I saw that a McDonald's
in Illinois came up with
a creative way
to recruit new employees.
Look at this --
the sign they put out there.
It says,
"Now hiring. Free iPhone
after six months' employment
and meet criteria."
Owner's gonna be thrilled
with his new employees
until the first day
of month seven.
[ Laughter ]
Some giant culinary news here.
I saw that DiGiorno
is coming out with a new
limited-edition
doughnut pizza mash-up
called the DiGiornut.
Here it is.
[ Audience groans ]
"It's not delivery.
It's disgusting."
It's perfect if you thought you
hit rock bottom with Bagel Bites
but still wanted to dig
a little deeper.
And, finally,
a skydiver in California
missed his landing zone
and wound up getting caught
in some power lines.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience ooh's ]
The good news is his Apple Watch
is charged for
the next seven years.
Hey, guys, before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in the commercial breaks,
but we want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
So it's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
-Tesla.
Netflix.
Carnival.
-Wow.
-Android.
[ Laughter ]
Lululemon.
Whey protein powder.
[ Laughter ]
Hydrox.
And, finally,
our last sponsor, Skype.
That's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."